good morning John I'm glad that you're
enjoying the majestic and exotic
Amsterdam so much here in Missoula
Montana we have something that I don't
think that you have in your little
apartment in Amsterdam and that is video
games I know that they have but I want
to talk about video games today I've
been playing portal 2 on my gaming
channel and it's super fun I've also
been playing Lego Harry Potter and
Assassin's Creed about to finish up
Assassin's Creed so I'm trying to figure
out what I'm gonna do next I grew up in
a different video game age and while you
sort of had control over the Nintendo
and it wasn't filled with poop I had to
play a different kind video game because
you were bogarting the grey box I was
playing a different sort of game two
dimensional game add a sort of game
simulation games that actually simulated
things and so with the hope that I will
educate people who were not around
during this era and provide a certain
amount of nostalgia for those of us who
are old enough to remember it I am going
to talk today about the best simulation
games of the 1990 so Mac sis it was a
company that pretty much created the
simulation game they started with
SimCity and then they tried to do
everything and they ended up doing the
sim which is they think the most popular
simulation game of all time you get to
pretend to be in person which is weird
you would think that people would want
to pretend to be something else besides
a person since they get to be a person
every day but yet so max has made sim
life where you got to sort of create
evolutionary biology and they created
him ant where you simulated an ant
colony and got to take over somebody's
house that was weird and sim health
which was a simulation of America's
health care system which unsurprisingly
was a nightmare and not at all fun it
wasn't like sim surgery it was like sim
HMOs in there was on a life service with
a sim farm which is like farmville
except actually a simulation of a farm
like for example if you don't feed your
pigs they die I have to borrow money
from the bank and you can sell your
crops on the futures market and the only
way to get rich is to plant a cash crop
monoculture because you're a farmer and
that's how it is and then there's Sid
Meier's Civilization a game that has now
had five incarnations all of them really
good and there's different ways to win
the game you can kill everyone which is
you know enjoyable for some people or
can find peace and the strength of a
diverse planet with lots of different
people maybe the warlike people will be
eradicated the people who love peace
can live together in harmony sim earth
another Maxis game was a simulation of
the entire planet like co2 levels and
ocean currents an actual interaction
that you have with the game was pretty
limited really it was just a textbook in
the form of a game which was good for me
because I was a little nerd and now I'm
gonna head with SimCity because of
course SimCity and SimCity 2000 best
simulation games of all time I got
SimCity when I was 9 years old so at
that ripe young age I got to become the
mayor of here's Vinod whether I wanted
to be a destructive or benevolent leader
I was always benevolent I I wish I could
say was destructive I never I never do
the evil thing in video games people who
have watched me play Assassin's Creed
are laughing right now that's because I
get bored with Assassin's Creed and I
just start stabbing people
I can hardly conceive of the amount of
stuff that I just implicitly know about
the world because of similars a
civilization that's the second time I've
done that that's the second take in
which I said simulation but more than
the truth about the world the facts that
I learned from simulation games what I
really love about them is that often
there's no winning there's no goal you
can't beat Sim City because that's one
of the weird things about life like we
don't know what what we're doing here we
don't know what we're supposed to do
different parts of society and different
cultures put different weights on
different things whether it's having a
healthy family or fancy cars or
comparing yourself to your co-workers or
making lots of money but unless you're
Charlie Sheen there's no winning you
never get to beat life knowing that I
get to decide for myself what success is
that's one of the most important lessons
I ever learned and I learned it from
playing simulation games so fancy that
John I know that you were busy playing
Nintendo games while all of this was
going on so I hope this wasn't too
boring for you but yes that is how I
became a nerd I'll see you on Friday